call it it's like women feel the need to  protect them I have so many times when  girls in my comments section will be  like why aren't you on our team it's  just like I'm like I'm just saying  what's true it's not even just a comment  section we've had it on a podcast had a  girl attack me  yeah  [Music]  I've seen that one I've seen that one  they took it down off of YouTube no like  women when women like this is a thing  women know  when their girlfriends or family members  are doing bad they're less likely to  acknowledge it which is why when you  talk about The Sisterhood when a woman  breaks away from the herd she gets  called to pick me you know she gets she  gets called all of these derogatory  names to try and bring her back into The  Sisterhood and shame her for actually  leaving The Sisterhood so yeah The  Sisterhood is uh is very real you know  it is very real also